never disclose the source write the word
never disclose the source if if you've
if
comma if you've promised confidentiality
to the source of the information but
don't you think that can be abused
abused by uh both sides meaning hey uh
yeah i think that yours are mine
something's happening okay all right so
like the the hey this dossier we got on
trump's uh meddling in the elections
with russia but it's a it's a source we
cannot tell you who the source is
because we have to protect the source
right
isn't that something that's abused to
constantly say
we cannot disclose the source of both
sides come out and trump will come out
and say we have to find out who the
whistleblower is you know when that took
place when he was coming out and then
schiff will come out and say you know
the the history of protecting
whistleblowers in america we have to
protect these whistleblowers it's always
protect the whistleblower when it's on
their side and it's always expose the
whistleblower and the source when you
say sides i again i i hear what you're
saying i know you don't like identity
politics
my whole mission is to fight against
that but unfortunately people
well i hear what you're saying but but
i'm living in a normative world i i
understand that that is the current
status quo when i was raided by the fbi
the aclu defended me which was so
shocking to to right wingers it almost
made their heads explode they couldn't
fathom this
okay like oh the what what party
appointed the judge that ordered the fbi
to stop well it was an obama appointed
federal judge
and i reject the premise that we have to
live in this world of sides because
there is only one truth now you you're
right i'm not saying you're wrong you're
you're actually describing the current
series of events where when the
whistleblower comes out against trump
who we want to know who it is
but
yes and no i think there are some people
that are
that are so political that they they let
their politics get in the way of these
values these primary values uh bart
nikki v vapor a supreme court case from
2001 when you want to live
in a society which places a primary
value on freedom of the press it's a
concomitant of life
you you have to live with this notion
that if the source gives you a document
from inside the pentagon or wherever the
white house
it could be the cleaning lady whoever
you protect the the identity of that
person and the reason some have said the
reason why
the aclu defended me after the feds
raided my home in november was because
they didn't want to happen to them sure
under a descent administration yeah so
so there still is in the venn diagram of
the you say side integrity a little bit
of integrity there's a there's an
overlap between the left and right in
this country and it's that overlap that
that little
overlap that gives me hope in fact i
want to expand the overlap when the aclu
defended this there you have it when the
ace of different that was a beautiful
moment i was probably one of the most
beautiful moments of my life
um because
i said to myself there are we are
finally talking about principles
we are talking about the things that i'm
going to sound like a hippie here so
forgive me but i believe i actually
believe this the things that unite us
are so much more powerful than what
divides us they ask us to focus on our
divisions but that right there is
beautiful that isn't that's an
incredible moment
and and then you have to say why is the
aclu defending james o'keefe and that's
the real conversation that's the
beautiful conversation that makes us
american that makes this country
wonderful because we give people
information and we don't disrupt the
right of people to get the information
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you